wird ihnen präsentiert von der leyen für
oliver länge oder weniger lang weg sind
nico gärtner und mike wittner aus ton
suchen das einfache leben mit ihren
kindern wandern sie aus nach costa rica
die adress- und marcel buholzer aus dem
kanton solothurn wollen noch einmal
durchstarten
auf kreta eröffnen sie eine bar von
clarus nach australien familie landolt
möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
im ferien resort freie krieg in
australien spitzt sich die lage zu
verkäufer will hat den kaufvertrag
gekündigt und will familie landet vor
die tür setzen
sie haben den vertrag gekündigt ist
abgelaufen
aber wir haben nun keine legale basis
mehr für unseren antrag ich verlängere
den vertrag um 14 tage
und diese investoren geben ihnen
trotzdem nicht das geld aus wird dann am
wie wäre es wenn wir darüber sprechen
was wir machen wenn die zusage kommt
gestehen so kurz davor neuen darüber
mache ich mir keine sorgen wenn sie eine
zusage bekommen wunderbar aber darauf
arbeiten wir hin und davon träumen hilft
nicht es ist kein traum wir sind mitten
in der risikoprüfung was passiert wenn
sie das geld nicht bekommen was ist am
wie gesagt dann ziehen wir aus in der
letzten folge von auf und davon hatte
schülern durch die rettende idee eine
tee beim fahren zusätzlich zu resort mit
diesem konzept will das geld auftreiben
für das projekt hat der geld bei einem
australischen investor beantragt
partystimmung auf kreta marcel buholzer
eröffnete seine bank einziger
wermutstropfen katze kasse ist immer
noch verschwunden
in costa rica plagte tochter josephine
das heimweh nicole gerstner kümmerte
sich um carla die frau des ehemaligen
hausmeisters sie ist krank ein gefäß
könnte platzen
die diagnose überforderte carla sie
hatte einen kreislaufkollaps
[Musik]
familie landolt rennt die zeit davon
alles hängt davon ab ob sie es schaffen
will von ihrem konzept das geld bringen
soll zu überzeugen wir sind ganz sicher
dass wir die risikoprüfung des
australischen investor es bestehen
innerhalb der frist bis zum 15
ja bis dahin werden sie etwas in der
hand haben sie sind sehr optimistisch
million
sie haben in den letzten zwei jahren
nichts zustande gekommen das ist ihre
perspektive wir haben bisher alle unsere
ziele erreicht das einzige was nicht
funktionierte ist der kreditvertrag weil
die bank kurz vor abschluss ihre zusage
zurück zog sie müssen doch zugeben dass
ihre art und weise wie sie geldgeber für
das resort suchen sehr ungewöhnlich ist
niemand macht das so sie hoffen dass
ihnen ein unternehmen 100 prozent des
grundstückswertes gibt dazu das geld für
eine tv in form von der sie keinerlei
know how haben
ich verstehe ihre zweifel aber wir haben
eine größere vision als nur dieses
resort zu betreiben wir wollen mit den
ureinwohnern zusammen arbeiten und dafür
braucht es unorthodoxe wege und wir
haben nun einen solchen gefunden
das ist jetzt der beste wie und die
beste möglichkeit und der schnellste für
uns alle
angenommen sie würden das resort wieder
übernehmen was machen sie dann nach dem
mit dem anwesen wir müssen wieder hier
einziehen wir können das nicht leer
stehen lassen sie sehr groß ziehen
wieder ein wir müssen was machen sie mit
all der buchungskanälen die meisten
gäste kommen über buchungskanäle welche
kanäle tv.com und booking.com was machen
sie damit werden sie die verträge mit
what if unter oder kündigen
fakt ist sie hätten bereits am ersten
oktober ausziehen müssen wir geben ihnen
noch einmal zwei wochen einen weiteren
aufschub werden wir ihnen auf keinen
fall gewesen
dessen müssen sie sich bewusst sein
[Musik]
bei
landolt haben den wunden punkt vom
verkäufer bill getroffen
er will auf gar keinen fall wieder
zurück auf dieses resort den er ist
gesundheitlich angeschlagen dass er da
irgendwie wird zog damit mit seiner frau
und aus über linz das für dich und die
schlimmste die slim-version und ich
glaube wenn er sieht dass jetzt auf
unsere vielen crx partner das licht wie
einfach nur das schriftliches dokument
das sind dran glaubt dass denke dass 114
glaube ich jetzt wirklich drauf dass das
funktioniert die nächsten zwei wochen
entscheiden über die zukunft von familie
landolt
[Musik]
mike wittner genießt an der playa santa
teresa das spiel mit den wellen mit der
walter älteste sohn joe
[Musik]
nicole gerster ist mit carla der frau
des ehemaligen hausmeisters immer noch
beim arzt nach ihrem kreislaufkollaps
geht es carla wieder besser
carla hat keine krankenversicherung
deshalb bezahlt nicole die konsultation
umgerechnet 80 franken kostet die
untersuchung des arztes die
behandlungskosten beim spezialisten sind
in costa rica ähnlich hoch wie in der
schweiz
nicole muss sich überlegen wie weit ihre
verantwortung für carla gehen soll
[Musik]
carla kommt ursprünglich aus nicaragua
für die medizinische versorgung könnte
sie auch dorthin zurückgehen
ich würde mich lieber in nicaragua
operieren lassen weil es dort viel
billiger ist
hier ist es sehr teuer weil dort als
einheimische gar nichts bezahlen muss
ich könnte bei meiner schwester wohnen
aber die reisekosten bis zu hier sind
hoch wir müssen uns nicht beeilen
wir können das ganz ruhig angehen und du
brauchst wirklich keine angst zu haben
vielen vielen dank
das ist doch selbstverständlich nicole
und mike müssen sich entscheiden wie
geht es weiter mit carla
[Musik]
für marcel und bertrich buchholzer
erfreuliche neuigkeiten
sie kommen auf vier pfoten engagieren
katzek asche war drei wochen spurlos
verschwunden
aber jetzt sind froh dass sie durch
einfachen regeln im ferienort an unique
urlaub verbringt ihr mann massen die
tage in seiner rock und blues bar
er wartet auf gäste für den katzen nahe
war die zeit ohne casting
wer selber sind nach unzähligen
plötzlich ist sie wieder auf und vor der
bühne stand oder respektive hinweg
standen in der bar hat marcel treue
kundschaft die katze der hausbesitzerin
kommt jeden nachmittag vorbei marcel hat
diese pina getauft es ist hochsaison
die anfangseuphorie hat sich gelegt bei
marcel ist der alltag eingekehrt
er hat nun drei angestellte und ist auf
umsatz angewiesen
[Musik]
wie immer kommt gegen abend ehefrau
tricks zum abruf vorbei mit gästen
ihr sohn manuel ist mit freundin andrea
zu besuch
die beiden verbringen hier ihre ferien
[Musik]
eigentlich wollten sie die bar jahr
gemeinsam betreiben aber dieser plan
ging nicht auf
das funktioniert nicht
das darf nicht so oder so gemacht und
die haben eigentlich auch mal das mag
ihr das beste ab
es geht nun aber das wird aber so
gemacht
[Musik]
buchholz haben die rollen in ihrer neuen
heimat klar verteilt in der bar ist
marcel der chef zu hause tricks das
sagen und kümmert sich um ihre
zahlreichen besucher aus der schweiz
[Musik]
da tochter rosalind planen mückenstiche
kallas unklare befund beschäftigt nicole
im internet versucht sie mehr über die
krankheit herauszufinden
nicole und versuchen gemeinsam einen weg
zu finden
sie kann er helfen können also ich glaub
die konsultationen zurück zu werden
explodieren und dann hab ich einfach
sechs nicht bestanden drei exzellente
dass sie taktisch sehr gut sagen wir die
antwort dass ich mir sicher massa muss
ja oder nicaragua
martin in the fields
das ist gut
sollte sich kallas zustand verschlimmern
werden mike und nicole die reise nach
nicaragua bezahlen
[Musik]
der hafen von a unique user auf kreta
verwandelt sich während der hochsaison
in eine ausgangs meine die restaurants
und bars sind gut gefüllt
[Musik]
am mischpult ist marcel in seinem
element
[Musik]
men in blue
marcel geht auf in seinem neuen leben
als barbesitzer er rückt das sap bis
tief in die nacht hinein
[Musik]
was ist los die polizei fast mitternacht
die musik in der bar ist zu lang ich
habe schon gemacht
ich habe es gerade gesehen es ist fünf
nach zwölf
sie können die musik an lassen aber
schließen sie bitte die türen schließen
sie die tür
ich habe fünf minuten überzogen
ja ist schon okay einfach türen
schließen
kein problem machen wir
[Applaus]
ich muss mich entschuldigen aber ich
muss schnell dem land wegnehmen als ich
die tür zumachen kann aber den ist
klimatisiert ist kein problem wir können
auch auf und wir halten bis 45 uhr
morgens das ist kein problem
[Musik]
nebenan aber bei der konkurrenz geht die
party draußen weiter und niemand stört
sich daran
marcel ist aufgebracht war nico versucht
zu beschwichtigen
[Musik]
marcels kampfgeist ist geweckt
die sache mit der polizei bilder so
nicht auf sich sitzen lassen
[Musik]
in australien läuft der countdown
familie lang gold bleiben noch zwei tage
ausgerechnet jetzt muss vater schuld
zurück in die schweiz
seinen sicheren job als finanzchef hat
er nach wie vor behalten aber schön ist
zuversichtlich dass er bald nicht mehr
um die halbe welt pendeln muss das
warten immer noch auf die zusage von
ihrem australischen investor trotzdem
ist die familie in feierlaune schüler
und miriam haben gelernt gemeinsam mit
hohem druck und ungewissheit umzugehen
gründet weiß was das bedeutet
als baby zum pflügen bringen oder und
ich sind so glücklich und wir sind mit
logo und müsse nicht sofort und lügen
also kummer
[Musik]
in ein paar stunden geht der flieger in
die schweiz
schön verlässt ein gut gebuchtes ferien
resort
[Musik]
in costa rica ist nach vier monaten
bauzeit das erste ferienbungalow
fertiggestellt simsalabim hatten mike
und nicole das haus getauft
es hat zwei schlafzimmer und bietet
platz für fünf personen
mike der gelernte zimmermann hat extra
nachtische gescheitert zwischen 120 und
250 dollar müssen die gäste für eine
übernachtung bezahlen
mike oft mit den einnahmen zumindest
einen teil der kosten der familie in
costa rica decken zu können
die ersten zahlenden gäste sind drei
freunde aus thun als gastgeberin kann
sich nicole eine zukunft in costa rica
vorstellen
aber damit ist die superstimme das
ventilatorensystem
[Musik]
am nächsten tag macht sich marcel mit
banner nico auf den weg zur polizei
[Musik]
was will will klarheit haben und wissen
warum er die türen seiner bar um
mitternacht schließen muss während gäste
in anderen lokalen draußen weiter feiern
dürfen
[Musik]
ehefrau tricks hat für sich eine
erfüllende aufgabe gefunden einmal mehr
fährt sie zum flughafen um besucher
abzuholen
diesmal erwartet sie tochter sabrina mit
enkelin lisa neun monate hat tricks ihre
enkelin nicht gesehen
tochter sabrina lebt seit mehreren
jahren in kairo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
m
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein paar stunden später in aion nicola
marcel dortmund zu wissen warum er die
türen schließen musste und in der bar
nebenan bis spät in die nacht draußen
gefeiert wurde
laut studie gibt es mitbekommen dass ein
dritter täter machen machen sie bei 1 2
wenn es sich handelt
wer eine busse bezahlt darf weiter
feiern
so scheinen die geschäfte in marcels
neue heimat zu laufen
in australien ist die zeit für die
familie ran dold abgelaufenen heute ist
der tag an dem sie ihre sachen packen
müssten aber die familie hält an ihrem
traum fest
für consol hatte ein großer baum will
lanxess zähle ich verstehe die frucht
australien gewonnen dann unvermittelt
eine nachricht auf miriams mobiltelefon
andritz haben die risikoprüfung
tatsächlich bestanden
die familie bekommt das geld vom
australischen investor ist ein live
support wo ganz große fahrt mit özil und
videos werden
ich war dass sie das finanzieren sie
dann sehr langfristig dh bis 20 jahre
und am armband rubin
ja wir ihren kann durchatmen die
finanzierung von freude krieg ist
endlich gesichert
[Musik]
beim abendessen darf der jüngste der
familie jannis den anderen die gute
nachricht verkünden
schon bald kann die familie das
ferienressort und die täter farm kaufen
[Musik]
vater schon wird die neuigkeiten beim
frühstück in drei haus erfahren
[Musik]
nicole gerstner ist mit ihren kindern
unterwegs zur schule
die drei hatten sich in costa rica
inzwischen gut eingelebt
die bogen haben freunde gefunden so hat
durch das surfen joaquín über den
fußball und auch josselin hat ihr
heimweh überwunden
josselin hat in den letzten monaten ganz
schnell spanisch gelernt
jetzt ist sie diejenige in der familie
die sich am besten verständigen kann
[Musik]
am fährhafen in paguera erwartet nike
seine drei freunde aus thun
mai kennt martin vom snowboarden
gemeinsam haben sie im berner oberland
wintersport events organisiert
die drei sind nur die vorhut morgen
kommen noch mehr freunde aus thun
martin tanja und anja gönnen sich eine
auszeit sie wollen drei monate in costa
rica bleiben ein stück heimat
die ihr seid aber der strand
[Musik]
oberhalb von rio nicolai wurden nach
wohnlage suchen marcel und tricks ein
größeres haus
sie brauchen ihr platz für ihre gäste
aus der schweiz
im internet hat tricks bereits ein paar
objekte ausgesucht nicht lange studieren
anschauen
das ist ihre devise
[Musik]
im nachbarhaus sind die rollläden
geschlossen das haus scheint nicht
bewohnt die beiden bleiben nicht
unbemerkt
suchen sie etwas ich hatte mich nur
gefragt ob wir das haus mieten kann
ich habe hier ein geschäft jetzt schauen
wir nach einem haus in der nähe von
radios für die nächsten fünf bis zehn
jahre kann man es kaufen auch nicht
alles klar
vielen dank tricks und masse gefällt es
immer besser auf kreta
[Musik]
für mike gibt es grund zur freude sein
freund martin hat drei neue surfbretter
aus der schweiz mitgebracht
[Musik]
er möchte in zukunft surfbretter nach
costa rica importieren
vor zehn monaten sind nicole gerstner
und mike wittner mit ihren drei kindern
aufgebrochen und der hektik des
schweizer alltags zu entfliehen
sie haben ein kleines paradies aufgebaut
geblieben ist das heimweh
[Musik]
ich hab das jemals ausweg 27 august für
sie so oft etwas das uns mitmacht und
befragen ist der station ist
aber er weiß ist sie sicher ist dass man
hier mit
[Musik]
der chef der ufa
berlin
nein
mike hat für sich einen neuen
lebensrhythmus entdeckt und mehr zeit
für die kinder
alex miescher das handy geklaut
[Musik]
die familie will sich offen lassen wie
ihre zukunft aussieht
mike nicole und die kinder haben ihr
glück in costa rica gefunden
aber nicht nur das sie haben auch den
wahren wert der schweiz wieder neu
entdeckt
freddy krieg ist etwas ruhe eingekehrt
sei der entscheid kam dass die
finanzierung gesichert ist
miriam kann sich wieder mehr zeit für
ihre kinder nehmen
nur vater schöne fehlt er arbeitet immer
noch in der schweiz
[Musik]
in australien leben und arbeiten
zusammen mit
mit dieser vision hat alles begonnen
dafür hat familie landolt ihr sicheres
zuhause in glarus aufgegeben hat sich
noch einmal thema sein
[Musik]
mit einem koffer voller geschenke macht
sich schön wieder einmal auf den weg
nach australien zu seiner familie das
leben im land der aborigines bedeutet
für 10.000 kilometer pendeln eine harte
zeit die nun bald ein ende findet bis im
herbst 2015 wieder die zelte in der
schweiz abbrechen
schön hat sich mit dem auswandern wir
sind überzeugt hat aber jetzt muss ich
sagen das ist gut und das ist ja auch
moniert construct hat das war irgendwie
diese therapie nach hause holen
es hat viel geduld und ausdauer
gebraucht um das resort zum laufen zu
bringen was sie ganz sicher wieder
angesprochen ist behandelt besonders
übernehmen als visum konnte und ducati
sagt kleinwächter oder sorgen solle
das ist natürlich für den amoklauf zu
fangen
[Musik]
nun scheint das pendeln ein ende zu
haben bald kann familie landolt in ihren
ferien resort down under zusammenleben
die glarner haben gekämpft eine trennung
und die halbe welt auf sich genommen und
immer an ihrer vision festgehalten
amman - beach verbringen marcel und
tricks den nachmittag
jetzt wo die wahl läuft gönnt sich
marcel einen freien tag pro woche
seit sich der kleine nager zu widmen
vor sieben monaten hat marcel buchholzer
seinen job als technischer vertreter in
der schweiz an den nagel gehängt
er lebt seinen traum und ist zum
barbesitzer geworden
auf kreta hat er nicht weniger arbeit
dafür aber erfüllung gefunden
[Musik]
auch tricks fühlt sich unter der
griechischen sonne daheim
sie hat die ruhe gefunden die sie immer
gesucht hat und nach einer hektischen
anfangsphase nun auch zeit die beziehung
zu pflegen
[Musik]
ein turbulenter weg zum gemeinsamen
glück
ich muss nicht die kälte
träumen
denkst du
[Musik]
und bevor ich infos präsentiert wurde
der leyen für oliver längert oder
weniger lang weg sind